des pauvres de plus en plus pauvres donc
en france selon le secours populaire
alors que le ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire s'est lui ai récemment
une performance exceptionnelle de
l'économie française on en parle tout de
suite dans notre décryptage
est avec nous pour en parler ce soir
bruno parmentier consultant et
spécialiste en questions alimentaires en
direct avec nous par skype bonsoir bruno
parmentier une autre avec nous sur ce
plateau henri sterdyniak économiste
membre des économistes atterrés bonsoir
henri sterdyniak merci d'être là alors
ce sont des chiffres évidemment alarmant
publié notamment par l'insee cette
semaine regarder un français sur cinq en
situation de pauvreté monétaire ou de
privation matérielle et sociale en
métropole c'est ça la crise du coc vie
de henry sterdyniak qui est responsable
de tout ça ou c'est un raccourci
c'est un raccourci aller le taux de
pauvreté en france est de l'ordre de 15%
il a sans doute augmenté en 2020 ils
devraient ils devraient se retrouver un
niveau de l'ordre de 15% en 2021
lorsqu'on regarde l'enquète du secours
populaire français bien sûr il ya
toujours entre 30 et 40 % de gens qui
déclare se priver pour aller en vacances
pour aller aux coiffeurs pour certains
même se priver de nourriture mais il n'y
a pas de très forte dégradation par
rapport à la situation de
2019 il ya ce que la crise a quand même
montré c'est la fragilité d'une partie
de la population à on a bien vu les
précaires
les marginaux et puis aussi ce qui a été
très frappant les étudiants entre qui
n'ont pas de prestations dédiées entre
18 et 25 ans avant de donner la parole
évidemment à bruno parmentier tout de
même vous bon c'est pas nécessairement
que la crise sanitaire par rapport à
2019 mais est-ce que ça a tendance parce
que c'est la question qu'on se pose
toujours à empirer d'année en année où
finalement pas tant que ça au fil des
décennies sont ça n'empire pas d'année
en année le fait est que
il est apparu de nouvelles précarités
en particulier liées au marché de
l'emploi les intérimaires les personnes
en cdd les personnes en sous traitance
toute la gamme si on peut dire des
photos entrepreneurs ce sont des gens
qui sont fragiles et qui vont tomber
dans la précarité dès qu'on a un choc
comme le choc du coc vidéo n'a eu une
prayssac d'une protection sociale qui
est très généreuse mais on a des trous
les 18
23 ans qu'on a oublié alors qu'eux ils
accèdent de plus en plus tard un emploi
stable et puis je le répète le
développement de la précarité qui est
une conséquence de la flexibilisation de
l'emploi alors cette estimation de
l'insee on peut là l'a confirmé en
recoupant certaines informations comme
celles fournies par l'institut de
sondage ipsos 1 dans son baromètre
publié par le secours populaire
regardez 20% des français en soit un
français sur cinq déclare sauter
certains repas les références parfois ou
souvent alors qu'ils étaient quatorze
courses en 2020 bruno parmentier vous le
spécialiste des questions alimentaires
c'est évidemment inquiétant vous l'avez
constaté vous aussi sur le terrain et
qu'est-ce que ça reflète
voyais alors relativisons la crise du
coc vite puisque réchauffement
climatique plus les conflits fait que la
faim dans le monde augmente de façon
considérable en ce moment mais la vraie
st c'est les gens qui meurent de faim je
vous rappelle que ya à peu près un
enfant qui meurt de faim toutes les 10
secondes sur la planète et oxfam a
estimé que
la fin grandi que il va y avoir à peu
près onze personnes qui vont mourir
à la minute au lieu de au lieu de
5,6 avant et 7 pour le coc vide donc la
faim tue plus que le comité maintenant
forte heureusement à corbeil qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure personne ne meurt de faim
ce dont on parle en france c'est des
restrictions des pénuries mais c'est pas
la fin au sens que
un risque vital alors maintenant on
tolère pas par parker n'a pas les moyens
de valablement j'ai donc correctement à
sa fin à chaque repas voilà maintenant
nous sommes un des pays du monde de plus
solidaire et on a vu quand même pendant
cette crise qu vide que le l'idée de
quoi qu'il en coûte a quand même été
impressionnant par rapport à d'autres
pays maintenant ça n'est pas parce que
on indemnise les gens qu'on met au
chômage parce que on oblige les magasins
où les usines de fermer qu'on couvre
l'ensemble du problème on il ya tout un
tas de tron alors ben les étudiants font
plein de petits boulots ya plus de
petits boulots ils ont plutôt en plus on
ferme le restaurant universitaire les
étudiants manche pour pas cher ils sont
obligés de compenser ça coûte plus cher
mais c'est pareil on a fermé les
cantines des écoles pendant un moment
ben les gens aux revenus modestes
mettent leurs enfants à la cantine et le
repas qu'ils payent coûte beaucoup moins
cher que ce que ce cas chez eux donc
toute cette frange cette marge qui est
difficile à saisir
s'estompe et les coûts augmentent
moyennant quoi mais les gens ont
l'impression de sombrer dans la pauvreté
est ce qu'on voit c'est que le secours
populaire le secours catholique les
restaurants du coeur ont beaucoup plus
de clients qui n'ont jamais eu alors que
justement ils ont du mal à
s'approvisionner parce qu'ils
s'approvisionnent surtout sur les gâcher
de la société alors quand il ya moins de
grossistes camp il ya moins de
restaurants et cetera ya moins de gâchis
c'est vrai que il ya d'un côté ce succès
extraordinaire qui est que la solidarité
sociale en france a été exemplaire
depuis deux ans et en même temps une
société a toujours des marges et c'est
très difficile de de compenser ses
marges donc il ya ces deux choses
l'économie repart mais tous ces petits
boulots et cetera toute cette économie
plus ou moins souterraine n'a pas encore
redémarré donc nous sommes dans une
situation où les gens sont frustrés
parce qu'ils ont l'impression de devenir
beaucoup plus pauvres effectivement
notre invité vient de faire référence à
nos ministres de l'économie qui a
annoncé partout que l'économie avait
repris des couleurs 6% de croissance
cette année 4% l'année prochaine selon
les prévisions de bruno le maire
c'est le figaro qui titrait ce matin des
pénuries de main d'oeuvre un peu partout
alors évidemment c'est toujours
compliqué de le dire sur un plateau télé
s'en aller vérifier mais c'est ce qu'on
nous dit en tout cas c'est un discours
en en trompe l'oeil de la part de bercy
qu'est ce qui cloche enfin en tout cas
expliqué nous cette cette perspective qu
on a du mal à avoir nous disons que
c'est un discours un peu en trompe
l'oeil à un camp dit y'a 6 % de
croissance c'est pas 6% de croissance en
fait c est simplement un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui en raison de la crise
que vides étaient fermés petit à petit
elle trouve que ce soit les hôtels cafés
restaurants les salles de sport et une
boîte de nuit est naturellement ça
augmente le pib il faut savoir
qu'actuellement il nous manque environ 5
% d'activité par rapport au niveau
normal qu'on aurait eu 100 la crise est
naturellement ça se traduit par le fait
que les ja de sureffectif dans l'est
dans les entreprises on a eu une
politique extrêmement généreuse de
chômage temporaire qui fait qu' il n'y a
pas eu d'augmentation du ya pas eu
d'augmentation du chômage donc troupes
tant mieux
le en 2020 le revenu global des ménages
n'a pas chuté malgré une chute du pib de
l'ordre de
9% donc la situation
n'est pas si mauvaise
l'activité repart
et dans un certain nombre de secteurs au
contraire on s'aperçoit que il ya des
pénuries de main-d'oeuvre parce que les
entreprises n'ont pas anticipé de façon
correcte la reprise donc elle se
retrouve à chercher des qualifications
qui n'existent pas par exemple dans
l'informatique dans un certain nombre de
secteurs les entreprises continuent à
proposer des emplois trop mal payés avec
des conditions de travail trop mauvais
dont ils ont du mal à les ailes et
fournir tout ça s'est relativement
satisfaisant ça prouve que le marché
fonctionne et on a eu aussi
disparition d'un certain nombre
d'emplois précaires mais d'autres
emplois précaires ont bizarrement été
créée par exemple toutes les livraisons
à domicile c'est c'est la situation et
il faut dire que par rapport à 2020 en
2021 quand même il ya un certain nombre
de facteurs de pauvreté qui ont disparu
puisque les écoles et les cantines
remarche c'est ce que nous disait bruno
parmentier bruno parmentier ce quoi
qu'il en coûte et surtout sa faim dont
nous parlait henri sterdyniak vous la
craignais justement vous malgré ces
belles prévisions de croissance oui
enfin il faut toujours regarder les
chiffres sur un peu un long terme quand
l'économie a baissé de 9% et qu'elle
remonte de six ça fait quand même moins
3 donc je veux dire faut plusieurs
années pour retrouver les situations
d'avant qui n'était pas génial bon donc
effectivement on a encore probablement
une à deux années qui vont être
difficiles
donc c'est normal les gens qui sont à
faire des jeux regarder sa part mais ça
avait beaucoup chuté avant
effectivement il ya des gens qui ne veut
plus qu'ils ne veulent plus faire le
métier d'avant et puis il ya beaucoup de
petits métiers
ben on parlait de la livraison à
domicile qui sont quand même très
pénible et très mal payés bon on a vu
par exemple au printemps 2020 les
frontières se sont se sont fermées on
s'est parlé on apporte deux cent mille
personnes de l'étranger pour récolter
nos fruits et légumes bon on a dit c'est
pas grave les gens sont au chômage ils
vont tous allés récupérer les fruits et
légumes mais ça fait pschitt parce que
c'est les métiers extrêmement pénible
vous êtes évidemment très mal logés et
vous êtes très mal payés et donc en
bombant heureusement après bambins les
étrangers sont revenus ramé chez nos
pommes et nord hainaut asperges mais bon
il va falloir forcément que le marché
acceptent d'augmenter les salaires des
métiers pénibles et des petits boulots
on va dire qu'ils régulent un peu le le
l'ensemble de l'activité donc tout ça
ben ça va créer des tensions sociales
pendant six mois un an deux ans en plus
on est en électorale donc ça va être un
petit peu compliqué mais globalement
quand on baisse de 9% économe en de 6
c'est pas génial de dire qu'est ce que
c'est bien regarder cette croissance oui
bon d'accord mais on était tombé très
bas donc on est en train de rattraper
seulement on n'a pas fini
parce qu'on arrive à la fin de notre
débat il faudra un moment donné comme le
suggère bruno parmentier augmenter les
salaires de ces petits boulots
effectivement pénible
normalement effectivement il faudrait
augmenter ses salaires il faudrait
améliorer les conditions de travail à la
fois dans le secteur public et dans le
secteur privé la france jusqu'à présent
comme on l'a dit s'est reposé sur les
travailleurs immigrés fraîchement
immigrés et sur les étrangers à qui on
pouvait confier des travaux mal
rémunérés et et pénible effectivement ce
serait bien que on revalorise ces
métiers de manière à ce que
effectivement ça devienne des débouchés
pour les travailleurs français si je
dire merci à vous henri sterdyniak
renault par vanter d'avoir été avec nous
nous avoir apporté votre éclairage
sur effectivement des chiffres qui
parfois ne veulent pas dire grand chose
il faut les mettre en perspective merci
à vous